lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en algunos límites que involucren
funciones trigonométricas así que
empecemos con un límite bastante
sencillo encontremos el límite cuando x
tiende a pin de el seno de x pausa el
vídeo y revisa si puedes obtener la
respuesta bueno tanto el seno de x como
el coste de x están definidas para todo
número real así que su dominio son los
reales
puedes poner cualquier número real para
x y obtendría un resultado ya que ésta
estaría definida y además es continua en
todo su dominio de hecho todas las
funciones trigonométricas son continuas
en su dominio así que como el seno de x
es continua y está definida en el seno
de pi
podemos decir que bueno pues esto va a
ser igual al seno de pib y como sabes el
seno de pi es igual a 0 y podemos hacer
lo mismo utilizando el concepto de x si
pensamos por ejemplo en el límite cuando
x se aproxima am apl y cuartos de coseno
de x
bueno pues una vez más la función coseno
está definida
todos los números reales y también es
continua y por lo tanto este límite va a
ser lo mismo que el coseno de pi cuartos
y esto es lo mismo que bueno la raíz de
dos sobre dos por cierto este es uno de
los ángulos que vale la pena saber su
cocina y su seno que de hecho si lo
pensamos en grados esto es lo mismo que
45 grados y en general déjenme
escribirlo por aquí puedo decir que si
estoy trabajando con un seno o un coseno
el límite cuando x se aproxima a am del
seno de x bueno es simplemente el seno
de amd y una vez más esto va a ser
verdad para cualquier número real que
tome a y podemos hacer una afirmación
igual para el coseno el límite cuando
extiende aa del coseno de x va a ser
simplemente el coseno de amd y déjame
decirlo de nuevo esto es porque sus
dominios son todos los números reales es
decir están definidas para todo número
real y son continuas en todo su dominio
bien ahora hagamos uno un poco más
difícil vamos a trabajar con algún
límite que no esté definido para todos
los números reales es decir que sus
dominios sean restringidos no se te
ocurra tomarme el límite cuando x tiende
a pin de la tangente de x bueno ahora
aquí va a ser igual esto ok esto va a
ser igual al límite cuando existen de
pib del seno de x entre el coste no de x
porque eso es la tangente de x y ahora
ambos están definidos para ti ahora lo
que podemos hacer es sustituir a pie en
ambos casos y simplemente verificar que
no nos dé cero en el denominador porque
en este caso esto sería un límite
indefinido entonces me quedaría el seno
de pib entre el coste no de pin lo cual
es cero entre menos uno lo cual es
completamente definido si tuviéramos
menos uno entre cero y si tendríamos un
problema pero en este caso simplemente
cero así que esto funciona bien hagamos
uno más ahora preguntémonos cuál es el
límite cuando x tiende a
y medios de la tangente de x pausa y ver
si puedes encontrarlo bueno siguiendo el
mismo razonamiento esto es el límite
cuanto x tiende a pin medios de el
cenote x entre el coseno de x ahora el
seno de pi medios es 1 y el coche no
deprime dios es 0 así que si simplemente
sustituye es esto te quedarían 1 entre 0
lo cual es indefinido otra forma de
pensar lo es que x igual a pi medios no
está en el dominio de la tangente de x y
por lo tanto podemos decir que este
límite no existe en general
si estamos trabajando con coche en homs
se notan gente con tangente secante o
secante si estamos tomando el límite
cuando x tiende a un cierto punto que
esté en el dominio entonces el valor del
límite será simplemente sustituir ese
punto en la función trigonométricas pero
si estamos tomando el límite de un valor
que no esté en el dominio entonces
tenemos una gran
habilidad de que ese límite no existe
así que en este caso podemos decir que
el límite no existe y la razón es porque
pi medios no está en el dominio de la
tangente de x es decir si tu gráfica la
función tangente vas a ver una cinta
vertical en x igual a pri medios bueno
hagamos un último ejemplo imagina que
queremos tomar ahora el límite cuando x
tiende a ping de la cota agente de x
pausa y de nuevo intenta ver si puedes
encontrar la respuesta bueno una forma
de resolver este límite es recordar que
el acotan gente de x es lo mismo que 1
entre la tangente de x que es lo mismo
que el coseno de x entre el seno de x
entonces queremos encontrar el límite
cuando extiende up in the air
y ahora si nos preguntamos si está en el
dominio de la cuota en gente de x vamos
a responder que no si sustituimos a pie
en esta expresión vamos a obtener menos
1 entre 0 así que esto no está en el
dominio de la co tangente de x y de
hechos y gráficas aquí verás una sin
tota vertical y por lo tanto no tenemos
límite déjame escribirlo este límite no
existe así que una vez más podemos decir
que este valor no está en el dominio de
la co tangente y por lo tanto el límite
es muy probable que no exista o dicho
otra manera si el valor al que
intentamos aproximarnos está en el
dominio de la función trigonométricas
entonces tendremos un límite definido y
el coseno y el seno en particular están
definidos para todos los números reales
son continuas para todos los números
reales así que si tomamos el límite
aproximándonos a cualquier valor real es
el límite simplemente será finito y va a
ser igual al valor que toma la función
en este
bueno pues hasta el próximo vídeo